for decades la suffree remained dormant
but late last week
huge eruption sent ash gas and rocks
spewing from its summit
probably 50 kilometers above the summit
now
the initial impact led to evacuation
orders for 16 000 residents
but on monday a bigger volcanic
explosion made a dire situation
worse those that didn't evacuate are
dealing with increasing amounts of
choking ash
water shortages and fear that more
eruptions may come
telling an ally and right now i feel it
because we don't know if we will get
back our home
the way holy the software look aid from
neighboring countries
is slowly making its way to this island
of a hundred thousand people
but the prime minister told al jazeera
the road to recovery will be hard
we can't see with mathematical precision
how long it's going to last
but this is a long haul we're going
gonna be in this condition
for four months perhaps or more but it's
going to take much longer time
to rehabilitate and to reconstruct so
far there are no reports of deaths or
serious
injuries from the multiple eruptions
those that live close to the volcano
were evacuated as scientists saw signs
of activity
in 1902 an estimated 1600 people died
during a violent eruption
those that remember the last eruption in
1979
say this is worse people looked up
and there is this huge plume of
ash hanging in the sky
silent deadly
dreadful omnibus and within minutes
you could just feel a change
in the mood in the town the volcano sits
on the northern part of the island away
from most of the population
but the threat to crops water supplies
and the health of those still on the
island is critical
saint vincent's prime minister says
normal life doesn't exist
and may not for some time andy gallacher
al jazeera